Speaker 1: Check this out. Marjorie Taylor GREENE
tried to make a statement about how not racist she
is, and in doing so, she made a horribly racist
comment. I'm going to play this for you. It is
some really, really wild stuff and I'll just
play it for you and then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 2: I know a ton of white
people that are as lazy and sorry
and and probably worse than black people I know.
Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE To prove to us
how not racist she is, says, You know what? I'm
not racist. Lots of white people are even as
or lazier then black people I know That might be
hard to believe if if you can believe this. There
are also lazy white people who challenge black
people for laziness. Did that just come out wrong,
Marjorie? Or am I misunderstanding what it is that
you were saying? There's actually a longer clip
that I'm trying to find. I see if I can find it
here, which gives a little more. More context.
Lazier, I think, would be the key word here. No,
I'm not able to find. Okay, So. This is really
a disgusting person. Really a disgusting person.
And during this same this was during like a live
that she did of some kind answering questions. I
don't know. She said on the issue of Confederate
statues, black people should actually be proud
of Confederate statues because it's a reminder
of how far the country has come. This is crazy.
Speaker 2: We don't want our statues taken down
in our country. I don't think you remove
or erase history. So I do I do agree those
statues shouldn't be taken down. They're part of
our history. We should learn from our history.
We don't erase it. But that doesn't make me a
racist, because I figure, as I say, leave the
statue out there. If I were black people today
and I walk by one of those statues, I would be
so proud because I'd say, Look how far I have come
in this country. Look how far my people have, what
they have overcome. And these are good things.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It's just like, you know, in
Germany, if they had Hitler statues, obviously we
would all say these are great reminders of how far
we've come. We used to have Hitler here, and now
we've come so far. And so the more Hitler statues
you have, the better reminder it is of how far
we've come. What an imbecilic thing to say. Now,
I have gone back and forth over the last couple of
years that Marjorie Taylor GREENE has been around.
As to whether she's really this dumb or whether
this is sort of a character she's playing.
This live thing really gives me the impression
that she's genuinely this dumb. I don't I don't
think this is a character that she's
playing. Let me know what you think.
But I have a very hard time believing that
this is staged in any sense of the word.